HAVE A FULL DAY AHEAD OF US
.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY.
DODD.
THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GONZALEZ.
GROVE.
HERTZBERG HILL.
WITH SO -- TITLE.
JACKSON JONES.
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO SKIP STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER Y. CASKEY WIENER.
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
DEACON SERGIO DHEAS OF ST IN AUG
IT COULD NOT CIAS PERISH IN
SACRAMENTO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ [inaudible]
YOUR GARDEN.
THANK YOU FOR BLESSING OUR LIVES
IN COUNTLESS WAYS.
INTIMATE EXPRESSIONS.
OF YOUR LOVE REALIZED IN THE
LOVE.
IN THE LIVES OF THOSE WE HOLD
DEAR.
ENTRUSTED WITH GRAVE
RESPONSIBILITY.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS.
EMBOLDEN OUR HEARTS.
AND IN LIGHT NOR MINES. TO LEAD
YOUR PEOPLE BY EXAMPLE.
GUIDE US TO LEGISLATE LAWS.
THAT UP HOLD THE GOD GIVEN
DIGNITY.
WITH WHICH YOU HAVE IN DOUBT
EACH AND EVERY PERSON.
TEMPER OUR QUEST FOR POWER AND
PRESTIGE.
WITH YOUR HUMILITY GENTLENESS
AND COMPASSION.
IMPARTIAL TO THE WEALTHY AND
WELL CONNECTED.
AND JUST TO THE POOR AND
POWERLESS [inaudible]
A MAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION SENATE
WILL FIFTY FIVE WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW LOBBYIST ON
THE FLOOR FOR TODAY'S FLOOR
SESSION.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AND LOOKING FOR SENATOR PAN.
OUR MEMBERS BEAR WITH US FOR
JUST A MOMENT
AS WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM PRESIDENT PRESENT HOWEVER
WE ARE SHORT.
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS ABOUT
[inaudible] SIX FOURTEEN IF YOU
ARE NOT HERE WITH US IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE SO THAT
WE CAN PROCEED.
CENTER PAN WE'RE ESPECIALLY
LOOKING FOR YOU
.
SENATOR PAN WELCOME.
MEMBER CENTER PAN IS GOING TO
PRESENT CERTIFICATES HONORING
SIXTEEN RECIPIENTS OF THIS
YEAR'S GRADE SCHMIDT SCHOLARSHIP
AWARDS.
SENATOR PAM AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS ASH.
TODAY I ACTUALLY THEIR FIVE
STARTERS A TYPE OF THEIR TODAY I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND
HONOR TO FIVE RECIPIENTS OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN GREG SMITH
SCHOLARSHIPS.
AWARDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FORMER SENATE
STAFF.
THESE SCHOLARSHIPS ARE AWARDED
TO CURRENT OR FORMER SENATE
STAFF OR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND THIS YEAR MEMBER HERE'S
WINTERS ARE.
THE MOTHER OF ALL RIGHT WE FIRST
WE HAVE CRISTINA NICOLE YOAKUM
IS THE DAUGHTER OF DOUGLAS
YOAKUM.
POLICY CONSULTANT TO THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS CRISTINO
RECEIVE A TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
SCHOLARSHIP.
CHRISTINA IS A POLITICAL SCIENCE
MAJOR AT SONOMA STATE UNIVERSITY
WITH PLANS TO ATTEND LAW SCHOOL
GRADUATE SCHOOL IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION OR FOREIGN
AFFAIRS.
THESE PLEASE THE CORRECT.
CONGRATULATIONS CRISTINA AND
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THE NEXT RECIPIENT THIS KATHLEEN
MARIE NAP.
IS THE DAUGHTER OF GABRIELLE.
MIDDLE CHIEF CONSULTANT TO THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
KATHLEEN'S RECEIVING A TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF REAL CAR
MARIKANA HIGH SCHOOL AND WILL BE
A FRESHMAN AT UC BERKELEY.
HE PLANTS A MAJOR MOLECULAR
ENVIRONMENTAL BIOLOGY.
CONGRATULATIONS KATHLEEN WELCOME
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
OUR NEXT RECIPIENT UNFORTUNATELY
IS -- NOT ABLE TO ATTEND BECAUSE
I UNDERSTAND HE'S OUT FIGHTING A
FIRE -- RAYMOND LEOPOLD
RODRIGUEZ THIS IS THE SON OF
CHRISTINE MORE HE WAS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR STRICT DIRECTOR FOR
FORMER SENATOR THE NEEDS TO
CHENEY.
RAYMOND WILL RECEIVE A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP
RAYMOND WILL ATTEND THE COLLEGE
OF THE REDWOODS WE'LL BE WORKING
TOWARD A FORESTRY DEGREE FROM
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY.
UNFORTUNATELY RAYMOND IS UNABLE
TO JOIN US HERE TODAY DO THIS
DUE TO HIS RESPONSIBILITIES
DURING FIRE SEASON BUT LET'S
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
OUR NEXT RECIPIENT IS MARY AND
D. HAYES IS THE DAUGHTER OF
GREGORY HAYES WHO WORKED FOR
FORMER SENATE PRO TEM THE DAILY
OUT AND FORMER SENATORS.
CLEA KEEN TAURUS AND JOHNSTON.
MARIANNE RECEIVE ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS SCHOLARSHIP MERION WILL
BE A SOPHOMORE AT LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY MAJORING IN
PSYCHOLOGY AND PLANTS A MINOR
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND EDUCATION.
ACTUALLY.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME YOUR
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
FINALLY WE HAVE BUT NOT LEAST --
WE HAVE ALEXIS RENEE TOWNSEND IS
THE DAUGHTER OF MICHAEL TOWNSEND
FIELD REPRESENT FOR SENATOR
CONNIE LEIVA.
ALEXIS WILL RECEIVE A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP SHE
ATTENDS OAKWOOD UNIVERSITY IS
MAJORING IN BIOLOGY ALEXIS
PLANTS BECOME AN OBGYN DOCTOR
SERVING MINORITY WOMEN.
CONGRADULATIONS ALEXIS A WELCOME
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SO AS WE CAN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING THE WINNERS OF
THIS YEAR'S SCHOLARSHIPS SENATE
COLLEAGUES IN STAFFORD BY TWO
RECEPTION IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
IN ROOM TWO ELEVEN HOSTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FORMER
SENATE STAFF AND IF IT'S ALRIGHT.
WE WE CAN HAVE A GROUP PICTURE
IN ANY OTHER CENTERS WHICH TO
JOIN PLEASE COME
REGULATIONS
AGAIN TO ALL OF OUR RECIPIENTS.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ABOUT A RESIDENT THE COMMITTEE
ON BUT IN FISCAL REVIEW TO WHICH
WAS REFERRED SENATE BILL ONE A
ONE REPORTS THE SAME BACK TO THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS.
A BILL THIS ORDER TO SECOND
READING.
REPORTS WILL BE DEEMED AND READ
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
HERTZBERG FOR PURPOSE TO RISE TO
PURPOSES FIRST AT THE REQUEST O
THE AUTHOR. TO ASK FOR REMOVAL
OF FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FIVE
FOUR A. B..
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN AND SECOND
REQUEST TO REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE A. B. ONE
SEVEN TWO THREE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDARS.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THEN RUBIO FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE.
THANK YOU AT MADAME HERE -- I AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THREE I'M SORRY NINETY THREE AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I ALSO HAVE A
SECOND REQUEST TO REMOVE FILE
ITEM. ONE THREE SEVEN AT THAT AB
THIRTY FOUR FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE. HUNDRED MOTION
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MADAM PRESIDENT.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MEMBERS
I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES FOR AB ONE ON ONE IN ORDER
THIS BILL TO THIRD READING I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
CENTER NIELSEN.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL IS
URGING AN AYE VOTE SENATOR
NIELSEN IS URGING A NO VOTE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN AYE AYE ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED.
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
GROVE NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
I WITH SO.
BY -- TADO.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO -- BURKE.
I LIKE COUNTY.
I WIENER.
AYE.
WILK [inaudible]
NO NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO.
I TWENTY NINE NEWS TEN THE
SENATE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
SENATOR ALLEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS I'D LIKE TO ASK IF
WE REMOVE AS C. A. TWO FROM AN
ACTIVE FILE THE DESK WILL NOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM ONE SEVEN ONE AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE DESK WILL NOTE THANK YOU
SENATE JACKSON.
IT'S THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH IS AB.
NINE TWENTY TWO AS WELL AS ONE
SIXTY SEVEN AB FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN AND ITEM FIVE A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT FROM TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR PURPOSES
OF A MAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN SEE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE AND ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE WE WILL START
WITH THE SECOND READING FILE.
MISTER SECRETARY WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY FOR THE
WOMEN'S FIVE TWENTY SIX WITH A
MOMENT SEVEN SIXTY THREE WITHIN
MOMENTS ONE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY WITH MEMBERS TIME FORTY
FIVE AT THE MOMENT FIVE THIRTY
NOW WITH MEMBERS FOUR SEVEN WITH
A MOMENT THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING.
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE HAVE
ONE BILL ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
RELATIVE TO COMPOST AWARENESS
WEEK.
SENATOR STERN.
YES I AM READY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS -- ESSIE OUR FORTY THREE
COMMEMORATES MAY FIFTH THROUGH.
ELEVEN TWENTY NINETEEN IS
COMPASS WHERE MEANT -- AWARENESS
WEEK IS BACK FROM ASSEMBLY WITH
CO AUTHORS ADDED I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL I WAS SO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK I'M REAL.
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
HI.
NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBER
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI. FIVE THREE NINE NINE ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS IN FRONT OF YOU YOU HAVE
SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
ONE THAT IS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
ITEM THAT WE TAKE P.
SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NO ONE BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
THAT GOING TO HOUSING AND MAKING
A PROVISION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELIGION
BUT CENTER MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT AND GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES AB ONE ON ONE IS THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS TRAILER
BILL.
WHICH CONTAINS STATUTORY CHANGES
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN IT
CONTAINS SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
AS WELL AS MAJOR POLICY CHANGES.
TO ADDRESS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THE BILL DOES
THE FOLLOWING IT PROVIDES FOR
THE DISTRIBUTION OF TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR CITIES COUNTIES AND
WE JUST THE PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
HOUSING CAPACITY IN COORDINATION
WITH THE SIX CYCLE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR HOUSING
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
STATE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT. FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY THE FINANCE MIXED INCOME
DEVELOPMENT. SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO ASSIST CITIES
COUNTIES AND THE CEO SEES
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS.
IT CREATES EXPANDED JUDICIAL
REMEDIES THE STATE MAY PURSUE
AGAINST JURISDICTIONS THAT FAIL
TO COMPLY WITH STATE HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW.
INCLUDING THE IMPOSITION OF
FINES INTEREST UP A FUNDS AN
APPOINTMENT AGENTS OF THE COURT.
IT PROVIDES A STREAMLINED
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR HIGH-QUALITY LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION
CENTERS THE MOVE HOMELESS PEOPLE
TO PERMANENT HOUSING.
IT EXPANDS AND UPDATES THE CAL
HOME LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
AND HE JOE CERTAINLY JUNIOR
FARM WORKER HOUSING PROGRAMS TO
ALLOW THOSE PROGRAMS TO BETTER
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
ACROSS THE STATE.
IT MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL OR
CONFORMING CHANGES TO OTHER
STATE OR HOUSING HOMELESS THIS
PROGRAM MEMBERS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB -- ONE OH ONE WHICH WILL --
HAS A NUMBER OF VERY VERY -- PRO
HOUSING -- COMPONENTS INCLUDING --
PUTTING US ON A PATH TO IMPROVE
THE VERY BROKEN RINA PROCESS SO
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY ASSIGNING
HOUSING GOALS BASED ON HOUSING
NEED -- WITH RIDE SIP
SIGNIFICANT -- NEW FUNDING AND
STRUCTURE THAT FUNDING -- TO
HELP OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- IN SUPPORT
OF HOUSING FOR FORMALLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE -- AS WELL AS INSURER --
THAT EMERGENCY SHELTER
NAVIGATION CENTERS CAN ACTUALLY
BE CITED -- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN HELP
TRANSITION PEOPLE OFF OF THE
STREET AND THE SERVICES -- THE
BILL -- ALSO PUTS -- TEETH --
INTO EXISTING HOUSING LAWS --
AND INSURERS THAT OR I SHE SENDS
A CLEAR MESSAGE THAT WHEN WE SAY.
THIS IS WHAT'S REQUIRED OF OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF
PLANNING FOR HOUSING -- THAT WE
NEED IT -- AND THAT THERE WILL
BE CONSEQUENCES IF -- THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN SO THIS IS A VERY --
GOOD PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I SUPPORT A I DO WANT TO
KNOW -- THAT THIS IS -- THE A
STOP IT'S A STRONG AND GOOD STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION -- BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
MORE WORK TO DO -- THIS BILL
FOCUS IS -- UNDERSTANDABLY ON
THE THINGS THAT I JUST MENTIONED --
BY WHAT WE STILL NEED TO DO WHAT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES NOT DO AND
SORT OF CRITICISM OF THE BILL
CAN'T DO EVERYTHING ON ONE BILL.
WE STILL NEED TO REFORM ZONING
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
STILL NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
EXPEDITE AND STREAMLINE -- THE
APPROVAL OF HOUSING -- WE STILL
NEED TO STRENGTHEN RENTER
PROTECTIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND UNTIL WE
REFORM ZONING SO THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY BUILD APARTMENT
BUILDINGS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN MORE PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
UNTIL WE ACTS WITH A HOUSING
APPROVALS SO THAT IT DOESN'T
TAKE THREE FOUR FIVE TEN YEARS.
TO APPROVE HOUSING -- AND UNTIL
WE PROTECT THE 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE RENTERS
BOAT AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHICH HAVE ALMOST NO PROTECTIONS
TODAY.
UNTIL WE DO THOSE THINGS -- WE
WILL STRUGGLE THE KEY PEOPLE
STABLE IN OUR HOUSING.
AND TO FILL CALIFORNIA'S THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOME DEFICIT.
BUT WITH ALL THAT SAID THIS IS A
STRONG STOP WE NEED TO PASS SAYS
AND THEN WE NEED TO TAKE THE
NEXT UP AND KEEP BUILDING.
UNTIL WE HAVE A BRIGHT HOUSING
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SENATOR
NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES DOWN THE
SENATE I JUST SUPPORT.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AS NOTED THIS IS A
CONTINUAL.
WE HAVE HAD MANY.
HOMELESS BILLS OVER THE YEARS.
SOME WERE TATTERED AS BEING THE
GREAT PANACEA NONE HAVE BEEN.
AND NONE WILL BE [inaudible]
MAYBE EVER.
BUT STEPS IN A CRIMINAL STEPS
CAN BE TAKEN.
THIS BILL DOES PROVIDE A LOT OF
RESOURCES.
AND SOME MOTIVATION FOR OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND THOSE MOTIVATIONS CANNOT ALL
BE PUNITIVE.
WHETHER THAT BE.
LITTLE TOWN OF WHEATLAND.
OR HUNTINGTON BEACH.
THEY HAVE TO BE ENCOURAGING AND
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IS THEY HAVE NOT HAD THE
RESOURCES.
OR THE ABILITIES. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL.
THE SALARIES AND ACCOMMODATION.
FOR THIS HOMELESS POPULATION.
WHAT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS THEY ALL FOCUS ON
THE SHELTER?
A PLACE TO LIVE IN STATE SLEEP
EAT.
THAT'S ONLY PART OF THE LONG
TERM IS DEVELOPING THE SKILLS
THE ABILITIES.
AND ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
THOSE OF THAT HOMELESS.
POPULATION.
THAT CAUSES THEM. TO BE
CONDEMNED TO THAT LIFESTYLE.
NOW MANY LIKE IT.
AND THAT'S OKAY IF THEY DO.
BUT A GOOD PORTION OF OUR
HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
FOISTED UPON THOSE COMMUNITIES
BY ACTS OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
THEY NEED HELP.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
SO MANY ARE OVERWHELMING OUR
LOCAL E. OURS NOW.
AND I'VE HAD MANY COMPLAINTS
FROM THE DOCTORS AT THE E. OURS
ARE THE NURSES.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SHOWN UP.
WITH NEEDS THAT THEY CANNOT MEET.
I SUPPORTED A BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THAT I'VE FORMALLY
NEVER WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED
GIVING A DOCTOR IN ANY ARE THE
ABILITY TO IMPOSE A FIFTY ONE
FIFTY HOLD.
ON A MENTALLY UNSTABLE
INDIVIDUAL.
E. OURS ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO DEAL
WITH THAT POPULATION.
BUT THEY'RE SHOWING UP ANYWAY.
IN AND I MUST SAY IN DESPERATION
I SAID I DO THAT BILL.
IT IS NOT THE ANSWER.
NOR IS JUST MORE MONEY BEING
POURED IN TO DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE.
WE HAVE TO ALSO FOCUS IN TERMS
OF THE LOCAL NEEDS AND RESOURCES
FOR JOB SKILLS AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND TO CREATE A POSITIVE
ATTITUDE WITHIN THOSE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY CAN BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THAT IS REALLY CRITICAL IF WE'RE
TO MOVE AHEAD.
IN THE FUTURE [inaudible]
AND ALSO.
THERE ARE PROVISIONS IN HERE
THAT I APPLAUD RELATED TO THE
NAVIGATION CENTERS WHICH I HAVE
A A STRONG AFFECTION. FOR TO
HELP THEM.
WITH THE SECRET PROCESS.
BUT LADIES AND GENTLEMAN UNTIL
WE IS THIS LEGISLATURE ADDRESS
THAT SIDE OF THE EQUATION THE
DRIVING UP COSTS OF HOUSING.
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE LARGER HIS
CONTRIBUTED TO OVER THE DECADES.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET A HANDLE
ON THIS.
THE COST OF HOUSING.
AND I WAS SUBMIT MY ARGUMENT.
THE VOICE OF A HOMELESS ADVOCATE
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE.
A VIGOROUS LONG TERM
[inaudible]
HOMELESS ADVOCATES.
AND SHE SAID DO YOU KNOW THAT
THE COST OF A HOUSE. FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL.
THE HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL.
STATE REGULATIONS AND LAWS.
ADDED SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THE COST OF THAT HOUSE.
NOW THIS IS NOT [inaudible]
SOMEBODY.
WHOSE LARGE CONSERVATIVE THAT'S
AGGRAVATED AT THE COST OR A
BUSINESS PERSON OR A BUILDER.
THIS IS A PERSON DEDICATED.
THE PROVIDING HOUSING.
AND SHE IS SAYING.
YOU'RE LETTING THE COSTS IN THE
RISING COST OF HOUSING.
GET COMPLETELY BEYOND OUR REACH.
DOES MEAN WE NEED TO EXPAND SOME
OF OUR REGULATIONS IMPOSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR AND VERY
SPECIFIC AREA.
FAR BEYOND JUST NAVIGATION
CENTERS.
IT CAN BE DONE.
IT SHOULD BE DONE.
THOSE ARE AREAS YET THAT DO
REQUIRE [inaudible]
ATTENTION.
THE WIRE JULY VOTE I WILL
INDICATE WE HAVE YET MORE TO DO.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT.
THERE IS AN URGENT MORAL ISSUE.
WE MUST CONFRONT.
THE HOMELESS EPIDEMIC.
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER AS A
STATE.
THE FOCUS ON PREVENTIONRAPID RE
HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH AND MORE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
BECAUSE WELL SHELTERS SOLVE
SLEEP.
ONLY PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SOLVES HOMELESSNESS.
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE OTHER
FACTORS BEYOND CITY PLANNING
THAT HAVE LIMITED OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE HOUSING AND IN RECENT
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
WE'VE. FOR THE JUDICIAL REVIEW
ON SEQUEL FOR PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS IT'S TIME WE DO THE SAME
FOR HOUSING.
THOSE ARE THE WORDS OF OUR
GOVERNOR AT THE STATE OF THE
STATE THAT WE ALL WITNESSED.
THAT WAS THE VISION THAT HE SET
FORTH AT THAT TIME.
WE ARE NOW HERE IN THIS HOUSE
CONSIDERING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE PAGE BILL.
WHICH IN LARGE MEASURE
ENCOMPASSES THAT VISION.
SOME OF IT'S A LITTLE TOO MUCH
DETAIL FOR ME TO COMPREHEND IN
THE SHORT TIME FRAME WE'VE HAD.
BUT IT IS LARGELY WITHIN THAT
FRAME.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE URGENT NATURE OF
THIS LARGER ISSUE IS THAT I AM
IMPATIENT.
IN THE CITIES THAT I REPRESENT
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE WHOLE
THE ISSUE OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS IS NOTHING LESS AN
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND WELL THERE ARE CERTAIN
REMEDIES IS PART OF THE
INCENTIVE THERE CERTAIN
INCENTIVES IN THIS CERTAIN
REMEDIES WE NEED TO DO MORE.
WE NEED TO WORK FASTER PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN GOVERNMENTNEED TO
WORK HARDER THE TIME LINES HAVE
TO BE SHORTER EVEN THOUGH IN
SOME PARTS OF THIS MEASURE.
THEIR SHORT IS SIXTY AND NINETY
DAYS  JUST MET WITH SOME
HOUSING ADVOCATES THE OTHER DAY
THAT WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT A YEAR
AND A HALF TIMELINE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT. FOR
LAND GIVEN SOME TO BUT THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IT IS NOT
FAST ENOUGH.
HOW WILL WE GET THE GET
NECESSARY CERTIFICATES OF
OCCUPANCY ON THE GROUND TO PUT
PEOPLE WHETHER IT'S SUPPORT OF
HOUSING OR WHETHER IT'S AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE LIKE?
THERE ARE SEEK WEB ELEMENTS IN
THIS MEASURE WHICH I SAW THAT
WERE THE CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
STATE OWNED LAND WE CAN MOVE
PAST THAT SMART IDEA TOUGH
MEDICINE.
IT'S ALL I SUGGES IS THAT WE
DEBATE THIS YEAR TODAY.
I THINK IT'S TO CELEBRATE THE
IMPORTANT EFFORT AND THE
EXTENSIVE EFFORT AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES.
BUT I TELL YOU THAT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED WE'VE GOT
TO MOVE HARDER WE GOT TO WORK
HARDER WE GOT TO MOVE FASTER.
I SUGGESTED I VOTE ON THIS
MISSION.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
BUT I WANT TO RAISE ONE ISSUE
WHICH SOMEWHAT FOLLOWS MY
CALLING FROM THE FAMILY VALLEY'S
COMMENTS -- WE HAVE IN THE BILL
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY
GOOD.
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW.
THE ON CONTINUUM'S OF CARE THE
COUNTIES THE CITIES TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS.
THE MONEY THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS. FOR SERVICES
TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
AND WE EVEN SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL.
THINGS LIKE EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE LEGAL ASSISTANCE SUCH
THINGS LIKE THAT.
YET OTHER PARTS OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
NEROLI DEFINE.
THE POPULATION FOR WHOM THIS
MONEY CONCERT.
AND IT BASICALLY THE NARROW
DEFINITION IS BASED ON A FEDERAL
DEFINITION.
WHICH STATES THAT THE PEOPLE
MUST ALREADY BE HOMELESS. FOR AT
RISK OF BEING HOMELESS WITHIN
FOURTEEN DAYS SO THEY LITERALLY
IT'S FOURTEEN DAYS AND THEY WILL
HAVE NO ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD.
NOW IN MY COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND I KNOW.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES CAN STAND
UP INSIDE THEIR PERCENTAGE
NUMBERS I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER
IN FRONT OF ME FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUT NO IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT [inaudible]
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
OVER TWO YEARS. TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS IN OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION COUNT.
GREW.
BY 47%. 47% [inaudible]
SO.
THIS IS A GREAT.
MOVE THAT WERE MAKING TO PROVIDE
SOME SUPPORT. FOR HOMELESS
POPULATION BUT IF WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE GROWTH LIKE THAT.
THERE'S NO WAY.
THAT WE CAN SERVE THE POPULATION.
THE ONLY BE.
ESSENTIAL THING TO DO.
IS TO MAKE INTERVENTIONS BEFORE
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS.
THE OTHER DATA [inaudible]
THAT.
LOS ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
HAVE SHOWN OVER THE LAST FORTY
FIVE YEARS.
IS THAT THIS GROWTH IN HOMELESS
A SIGNIFICANT PERCENT.
OF THESE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE NOW HOMELESS.
WE'RE NEVER HOMELESS BEFORE.
SO THEY WERE HOUSED.
THEY HAVE JOBS.
THEY'RE NOT MENTALLY ILL.
THEY ARE NOT ADDICTED MANY HAVE
FAMILIES [inaudible]
BUT THEY FACE ANY NUMBER OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH OUR HIGH HIGH
COST OF HOUSING.
THAT PUT THEM IN THE POSITION.
OF EITHER BEING A VICTIM OR
THREATENED WITH EVICTION NOW
MANY PEOPLE AND IN READ THE BOOK
AFFECTED OR ASK YOUR OWN COUNTY
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
MANY PEOPLE WILL LEAVE THEIR
HOUSING.
AND BECOME HOMELESS BEFORE THEY
ARE AFFECTED JUST TO PREVENT
HAVING AN EVICTION.
ON THEIR CREDIT REPORT BECAUSE
ONCE YOU HAVE AN EVICTION IT IS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. TO THEN FIND
SOMEONE WHO WILL READ TO YOU.
SO THEY IT YOU DON'T HAVE IF WE
LIMIT.
OUR ABILITY TO ASSESS TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS TO ONLY THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WITHIN FOURTEEN
DAYS.
IT IS BOTH TO NARAL THE WINDOW
TO REALLY HELP THEM.
AND TO NEAR OVERPOPULATION. TO
PREVENT THIS INCREDIBLE RISE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND IT IS FAR MORE
AFFORDABLE. TO KEEP PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOUSED IN THEIR PLACES.
WITH THE ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
THEN TO ONCE THEY BECOME
HOMELESS GET THEM HOUSE.
SO I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO WHEN WE
RETURN IN AUGUST THAT THERE IS
SOME CLEAN UP LANGUAGE.
THAT HELPS CLEAR FI SO THAT
THOSE ENTITIES THAT APPLY FOR
THIS FUNDING HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE FLEXIBILITY AS THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL SEEMS TO
INTENT. TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME.
HOMELESS PREVENTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI THANK
YOU MA'AM PRESENT I'LL BE SHORT
I JUST WANTED.
TO REMIND MEMBERS ABOUT THE
REQUIREMENT THAT CITIES ALREADY
HAVE TO HAVE THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT UPDATED EVERY.
FOR AT LEAST EIGHT YEARS MAYBE
FIVE YEARS AND THAT IT THE LAW
ALL ALREADY ALLOWS STATE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THREE FOR
CASE OVER -- TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IT IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL --
PROVIDE SOME FAIRNESS ADDITIONAL
FAIRNESS SO NOW THAT EIGHT EIGHT
CD IS GOING TO EITHER TELEPHONE
OR MEET WITH THE CITY THAT HCD
DOESN'T HINK THAT THEY'RE
COMPLYING WITH THEIR BACK
HOUSING ELEMENT AND PROVIDE THEM
IN WRITING EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
THE CHANGES THAT THEY NEED TO
COULD TAKE WHICH ISN'T ANOTHER
BITE AT THE APPLE IF YOU WILL
THEN IF THEY DON'T COMPLY THEN
WE REFERRED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO WILL GOING.
TO COURT TO SEEK SOME REMEDIES
BUT HAVE THE COURT THE TERM THE
JUDGE DETERMINE INDEPENDENTLY
WITH A SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLY SO
ONE WOULD.
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE MAY BE
EIGHT C. D. THE COURT SAYING
THAT YOU ARE IN COMPLIANCE BOARD
EIGHTY WHAT THE COURT SAYING NO
EIGHT CD IS RIGHT YOU'RE NOT A
COMPLIANT BUT EVEN AFTER THAT IN
THE BOND AND SERVE FAIRNESS.
IT GIVES THE CITY'S ANOTHER YEAR
BEFORE ALL THESE FINE START
CLICKING AND THEY THEY MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION SO IT'S NOBODY I
THINK SHE SHOULD BE CAUGHT OFF.
ARE OFF -- HAND NOT KNOWING
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BUT
FINALLY I AM VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT THAT THE PROVISIONS THAT
TALK ABOUT THE CAL HOME PROGRAM.
IDENTIFYING EXCESS REACH WELLING
UNITS AS A AS A EXCELLENT
CANDIDATE FOR CITIES TO GIVE OUT
LOANS TO AND SEEK AND SICK
FUNDING FOR JUNIOR ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY REPRESENT
WHAT THAT.
ALERTS AND I'VE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WHY KELSEY
SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THERE ARE
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT HEY WHAT'S REFERRED TO AS
SEVERELY OVER BURDENED.
QUANTITIES A RENT.
PERCENTAGE OF RENT OF THEIR
INCOME SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT ARE AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY SAID.
THEY ARE THE PRE HOMELESS.
THERE THE PRE HOMELESS.
THEY ARE NOT AS SHE SAID.
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OR WHO NEED SKILLS TO BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE FORCED
INTO LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
OR SOMEONE ELSE'S SO FAR OR
WORST ON THE STREETS OR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE JOBS.
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS DON'T
GET PAID ENOUGH. TO PAY THE RENT
IF WE SUPPORT THAT THEY SHOULD
BE PAYING THOSE RENTS THAT'LL
MAKE ENOUGH.
AND THE RENT IS TOO HIGH.
TEACHERS LIVING IN THEIR CARS
AND STUDENTS ARE WORKING.
AND THEY ARE PAYING THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PAY THE RENT.
SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT.
THIS CONVERSATION IS I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SPOKE IN SUPPORT AND I WILL
SUPPORT AND VOTE THIS. FOR THIS
BILL NO DOUBT ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT'S A DRESSING TWO KEY
COMPONENTS.
BUT THE OTHER KEY COMPONENT IS
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THE
CONTINUING MASSIVE NUMBER OF THE
VIC SHINS.
THAT ARE FORCING MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN INTO THE STREETS.
BUILDING LOW INCOME HOUSING IS
SO IMPORTANT.
BUT THE REASON WE WANT LOW
INCOME HOUSING IS BECAUSE THOSE
FAMILIES ARE HAVING A LOW INCOME.
SO WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT.
THIS IS A BROTHERS I'M GOING TO
KEEP USING THIS NUMBER OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
700-100-0 THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
SEVERELY PAYING SEVERELY OVER
BURDENED RENTS.
WE SHOULD NOT BE STUNNED OR
SHOCKED.
BUT THE CONTINUING NUMBER OF
HOMELESS IF WE IGNORE.
FAMILIES LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS SO SEE
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
SORRY CENTER MORLOCK PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRESIDENT I'M
ALSO -- IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE A
ONE IN. ONE OF THANK THE
GOVERNOR.
FOR THE ABILITY TO INTEGRATE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME THE TWO BILLION
DOLLAR.
FUNDING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT AS A RESULT --
PROPOSITION -- TWO BECAUSE A BIG
COMPOUND OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AS INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE MENTALLY ILL AND THEY'RE
ALSO GRAVELY DISABLED AND CAN'T
EVEN TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
SO IF WE COULD -- FURTHER SOME
SUPPORT OF HOUSING THAT WOULD BE
A POSITIVE THING.
WE SHOULD ALSO BE LOOKING AT
WHAT WE DO WITH THOSE THAT
CANNOT TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
AND WHETHER WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT WHETHER IT'S ALL VOLUNTARY
HOUSING OR MAYBE A COMPONENT OF
INVOLUNTARY HOUSING MIGHT BE
HELPFUL TO HELP THESE PEOPLE GET
BACK.
THE ROAD RECOVERY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER WARLOCK SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES --
FOR IMPORTANT DIALOGUE ABOUT A
CRITICAL ISSUE IMPACTING EVERY
RESIDENT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAIN I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE IN AB ONE A ONE THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY.
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO BY OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I HAMBURG.
IA CASKEY.
I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI.
I THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES
.
OR I COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO SENATE THIRD READING
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FILE ITEM THIRTY BY
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA CANDY MONTH SENATOR
DODD THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
AS A MEMBERS THIS RESOLUTION
DECLARES JUNE CALIFORNIA CANDY
MONTH.
DAHLE KEEP THIS SHORT AND SWEET.
IT CALIFORNIA KATIE
MANUFACTURING CREATES TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS IT HELPS TO
SPUR ON THE ECONOMY.
THE KID THE INDUSTRY IS
COMMITTED TO ALWAYS A TREE IN
INITIATIVE PROVIDING CONSUMERS
WITH SMALL PACKAGE SIZES AND
CLEAR CALORIE LABELS ARE
REMINDERS OF ALL THINGS IN
MODERATION.
I WON'T SUGAR COAT IT MEMBERS
I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG YOU SURE YOU
WANT TO TAKE THIS UP.
ALL RIGHT THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR --
HE THANK YOU MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT CAT ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE MANUFACTURERS OF CAVITY
FILLING COMPANIES I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AND WEIGHT REDUCTION ADDED TO IT
CERTAINLY YEAH SENATOR.
GROWTH DO YOU WISH.
TO NO TEMPTATION THERE.
ANYONE ELSE SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESENT CENTERS
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
HELLO DEAR SENATOR DODD WE DO
ACCEPT THE QUESTION.
YES ALL RIGHT SENATOR PAN SO HAS
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION TAKEN THE POSITION
ON YOUR RESOLUTION.
NOT THAT I'D GO TO US.
BUT YOU KNOW IT ALL THINGS IN
MODERATION AS I SAID BEFORE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
BOTH SONGS VERY TO A DENNIS OUT
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WHEN
THE ROLL CALL COMES.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION AND
I ASSUME THAT WAS YOUR CLOTHES
SENATOR DODD.
WE ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONCE WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO
ARE OVER IN THE ASSEMBLY WE WERE
GOING TO TAKE UP.
ASSEMBLY BILL'S GOING FORWARD
AND WE WILL ALSO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONCE AND PUT THEM ON CALL.
AS WELL SO.
MISTER SECRETARY ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OUR ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ.
I GROW.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- FOLLOW.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
I MOORLACH [inaudible]
BY AMARILLO [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I HAMBURG.
IA CASKEY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
HI SENATOR DODD MOVES TO CALL.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO FILE ITEM.
FORTY TWO IS THERE A SOMEONE TO
TAKE UP THIS ITEM.
I'M SORRY SENATOR STERN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AN ACCOLADE CONTRACTS.
SENATOR STERN I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION PASSED A REGULATION
KNOWN AS THE HOLDER RULES ALL
THE RULES SAYS THAT.
THE VENDOR COMMITS FRAUD. TO
SELL A PRODUCT AND ARRANGE A
LOAN TO FINANCE THE SALE THE
FINANCING COMPANY IS LIABLE FOR
THE DAMAGES SUFFERED TO THE
CONSUMER.
THIS REGULATIONS WORK WELL FOR
MANY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
ENCOURAGING FINANCING COMPANIES
TO POLICE THEIR VENDORS AND
ENSURE THE VICTIMS HAD ATTORNEYS
WERE WILLING TO REPRESENT THEM.
WE KNOW WORKED WELL AND IN HARM
LENDING AN EXPANDED CONSUMER
CREDIT INFECTED LAST FORTY YEARS
BUT LAST YEAR THE THIRD DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEALS ISSUED A
DECISION THAT RADICALLY CHANGE
THE INTERPRETATION OF THIS RULE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S SAID THAT ATTORNEYS FEES
FOR FRAUD VICTIMS MUST BE PAID
OUT OF THE VICTIMS DAMAGES NOT
PAID SEPARATELY BY THE FINANCING
COMPANY.
SO IF YOU PAID FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR FOR INSTANCE FOR THAT
FLOOD DAMAGE LIMóN YOU AND YOUR
ATTORNEYWOULD HAVE TO BE PAID
OUT OF THAT.
FIVE THOUSAND AS A AS A RESULT
MANY ATTORNEYS ARE UNWILLING TO
TAKE THESE CASES AND FRAUD
VICTIMS HAVE NO BE NO WAY OF
BEING MADE WHOLE.
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE WOULD
SIMPLY RESET CALIFORNIA LAW TO
HOW WOULD WORK.
FROM 1-975-220-0017 AND ENABLE
THE FRIDAY CUSTOMERS TO FIND
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE RANGE OF GROUPS INCLUDING
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
CONSUMERS FRAUD A RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY AND THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE
[inaudible]
BATES.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT OFF.
I CHIANG.
DELI [inaudible]
DODD.
ARE THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SO -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO -- BURKE [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
NO.
SENATOR STERN MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY INTO INSURANCE.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
OF FLOOR JACKING FOR ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WEBER A. B FIFTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH CODIFIES AN EXISTING
BEST PRACTICE IN THE MARKETPLACE
TODAY BY CLEAR FINDING CONSUME A
CONSUMERS RIGHT TO CHOOSE EITHER.
CASH PAYMENT OR TO HAVE THEIR
VEHICLE REPAIR.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE HAS FOUND THAT A SMALL
HANDFUL OF INSURERS HAVE A NO
CASH SHOP PROVISION IN THEIR
CONTRACT.
IF THE CONSUMER IS IN AN
ACCIDENT THAT CAUSES MODERATE
DAMAGE TO THEIR VEHICLE THEY
COST TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
REPAIR AND THE CONSUMER HAS A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE
THESE INSURERS WITH A NO CASH
SHOP PROVISION WILL REFUSE TO
ISSUE THE FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR
PAYMENT -- TO THE CONSUMER
UNLESS THEY SHOW PROOF THAT THE
REPAIRS WERE ACTUALLY MADE.
FORCING A FINANCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED CONSUMER TO CHOOSE
THE TO REPAIR THEIR VEHICLE AND
NOT COLLECTING ANY CLAIM PAYMENT
AT ALL IS UNFAIR.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TROUBLING FOR
LOW INCOME DRIVERS WHO HAVE
DUTIFULLY PAID THEIR PREMIUMS ON
TIME THE DANE BUT MAY NOT HAVE
FUNDS TO COVER THE THE THE
DEDUCTIBLE.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT A
FIRST PARTY AUTOMOBILE PHYSICAL
DAMAGE CLAIM IT MAY OPT TO
RECEIVE A MONETARY PAYMENT BASED
ON VALUE THE DAMAGE TO THE
VEHICLE.
IN LIEU OF HAVING THE VEHICLE
REPAIRED.
IT'S SPONSORED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
I CAN BE A REAL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ HI GROWTH
[inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible] FOR
TITLE.
HI JACKSON HI BY JONES
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BOB AKOWSKI I WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MITCH MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FORTY NINE SENATOR GONZALEZ.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE THIS
ITEM UP ALBUM ALL RIGHT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACT
REALLY INTO MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICTS SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU SO AB FIVE NINETY ONE
BUT FOR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AUTHORED AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY FOUR WHICH
CREATED A NEW GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE FOR THE CENTRAL WATER
BASINS ARE CENTRAL BASIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. TO
ADDRESS SERIOUS CONCERNS --
ETHICS -- CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BY CALIFORNIA AUDIT
REPORT THE LIST OF CONCERNS WAS
LONG THEY RANGE FROM A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP AND TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE THAT RESULTED IN
CREDIT DOWNGRADES OF OVER TWO
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND FORTUNATELY.
BEING SPENT WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT FROM IN IN AN
APPROPRIATELY SET UP LEGAL TRUST
FUND TO AN FBI INVESTIGATION.
THIS BILL EIGHT B. FIVE NINETY
ONE SIX TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF A REPRESENTATIVE
IN RESPONSE TO LITIGATION OVER
THE MEANING OF REPRESENTATIVE.
WE HOPE THAT THIS CHANGE WILL
MAKE CLEAR TO ALL PARTIES
ORIGINAL INTENT IN AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CENTRAL WATER
BUSINESSES ASIAN. TO ENSURE THEY
REMAIN ON TRACK WITH
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND REYES HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ SENATOR HERTZBERG
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
CAN I SAY NO.
YOU ARE YOU DON'T HAVE TO ACCEPT
BUT WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
ACCEPT WHAT I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ACCEPTED RIGHT WHY NOT.
ALL RIGHT TO BE KIND SENATOR.
YOUR KNOWLEDGE IS THIS MEASURE
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS WHAT
OTHER ALTERNATIVE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES.
WERE CONSIDERED -- WITH RESPECT
TO THE ISSUES FACING CENTRAL
BASIN CERTAINLY ALL OF US WHO
READ THE NEWSPAPERS NO THERE
BEEN CHALLENGES.
BUT OBVIOUSLY -- HOW DID THEY
ARRIVE AT THE CONCLUSION THAT
YOU DID HERE WITH RESPECT TO THE
MEASURE BEFORE US [inaudible]
HELLO.
YES FOR WHAT PURPOSE SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU AND PRESERVE A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY PLEASE --
BUT IS THAT INQUIRY I'D LIKE TO
FIND OUT -- FROM THE PRESIDENT.
IF THE QUESTION IS IN ORDER --
WITH THE THAT ISSUE IS BEING
PRESENTED THANK YOU.
OUR S THE QUESTION THE QUESTION
IS IS THE QUESTION IN ORDER
RELATIVE TO THE BILL THAT'S
BEING PRESENTED -- IT MAY BE A
STRETCH SENATOR BUT I BELIEVE
ACTUALLY THERE IS A SLIGHT NEXUS.
OUR TO THE ISSUE AT HAND SO
SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THE OTHERS I WOULD LIKE TO
ANSWER.
PLEASE FEEL FREE WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION I AM
UNCERTAIN OF THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES BUT I DO KNOW THIS
CAME FROM A HUNTINGTON PARK --
LAWSUIT -- WHERE THEY WERE
UNCLEAR AS TO WHAT THE
DEFINITION OF REPRESENTATIVE
ACTUALLY MEANT THEY HAD?
SOMEONE WHO IS -- INTERESTED IN
RUNNING BUT WASN'T THAT PERHAPS
WASN'T ELIGIBLE BECAUSE HE WAS --
ON ANOTHER WATER BOARD AND THERE
WAS SOME CONFUSION OVER THAT FOR
JUST.
I ASK YOU TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I COULD I COULD I ASK A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION -- NO I THINK WE'RE
GOOD.
ALRIGHT WELL DONE ANY FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION OR NEW
MEMBER BAITING.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THAT IS ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
BY COMING AT ALL.
HI JANE.
DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ.
HI.
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO --
TITLE.
I JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL.
BY NELSON.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
BY AMBERG.
OUR CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
SENATOR UMBERG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY INTO ELECTIONS SENATOR
UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS.
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
ALSO KNOWN AS SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION IS A SAFETY NET FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO MISSED THE
DEADLINE TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
CURRENTLY A CONDITIONAL VOTERS
GIVEN A PROVISIONAL BALLOT WHICH
IS PROCESS AFTER ELECTION DAY.
DURING THE CANVAS PERIOD.
USING VOTE CAL THE STATE'S NEW
VOTER DATABASE ELECTION
OFFICIALS CAN NOW VERIFY VOTERS
ELIGIBILITY IMMEDIATELY.
AND UPDATE THE DATABASE REAL
TIME.
THAT MEANS THAT THE SAME PROCESS
TO VERIFY CONDITIONAL
REGISTRANTS ELIGIBILITY THAT
CURRENTLY KERR'S ON THE BACK AND
AFTER ELECTION DAY CAN NOW
HAPPEN ON THE FRONT AND IN REAL
TIME.
AB SIX NINETY THREE WOULD
AUTHORIZE AN ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
TO OFFER A NON PROVISIONAL OR
REGULAR BALLOT TO A
CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTER
PROVIDED THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
COMPLETES THE VERIFICATION.
UNDER A CERTAIN SET OF ESTABLISH
CONDITIONS.
IF A LITTLE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
CANNOT VERIFY OR THE CONNECTION
TO THE VOTER DATABASE IS
INTERRUPTED ANYTIME.
THE VOTERS WOULD STILL BE ISSUED
A PROVISIONAL BALLOT THIS BILL
WILL IMPROVE THE VOTER
EXPERIENCE AND LOWER THE NUMBER
OF PROVISIONAL BALLOTS THAT ARE
THE THE NEED TO BE PROCESSED
AFTER.
ELECTION DAY VIRGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING ON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I HARSH LETTER.
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DOT.
I TO RUSSELL BY GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
I GROW.
NO HERTZBERG I HAVE AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO [inaudible] FOR TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO NUMBER.
I WORK OUT SEE [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
NO.
SENATOR UMBERG MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MON AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC LANDS
SENATOR MONNING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN SADDLED WITH
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN EXPENSES TO PLUG
ABANDONED OIL WELLS OFF OF OUR
COAST.
WHAT WE CANNOT ELIMINATE OUR
CURRENT FISCAL OBLIGATIONS WE
CAN WORK TO PREVENT AND REDUCE
OUR FUTURE FISCAL OBLIGATIONS
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB?
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE THE BILL
CODIFIES EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL CRITERIA IN REQUIRES THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO
EVALUATE WHETHER PROPOSED
ASSIGNEE IS LIKELY TO COMPLY
WITH THE TERMS.
OF THE ASSIGNED TO OIL GAS AND
MINERAL LEASE OR PERMIT.
MEMBERS AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT OFFSHORE OIL
OPERATORS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE WELLS THEY DRILL.
AFTER THEIR DECOMMISSIONING I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR JACKSON
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES  A TO JOIN IN THIS I
THINK VERY CRITICAL BILL.
YOU KNOW THE TAXPAYERS OF THIS
STATE DESERVE BETTER.
THAN THIS TAXPAYER HAVING TO
FOOT THE BILL WHEN THESE
COMPANIES GO OUT OF BUSINESS OR
OTHERWISE HAND BACK THEIR DEEDS
TO THE STATE AND SAY.
THE MASS TO CLEAN UP IS ON YOU.
AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT
WE'RE HAVING AND RIGHT NOW IN
THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEóN BEING
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN IN MY
DISTRICT KNOWS VERY WELL.
THAT RIGHT NOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD TO PAY OVER
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
COUNTING. FOR THE REMEDIATION
AND THE DECONSTRUCTING OF AN OIL
PLATFORM TWO OF THEM ACTUALLY
OFF THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I JOIN IN THIS SO I THINK
THIS IS A BILL THAT IS A
TAXPAYER PROTECTION BILL THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD BE SUPPORTING.
YOUR RESPECTIVE OF THE NATURE OF
THE INDUSTRY WHEN THEY WALK AWAY
LEAVING US TO CLEAN UP THEIR
MESS.
AND HAVING THE TAXPAYER FOOT THE
BILL THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG AND
THIS IS A FIRST STEP TO TRYING
TO CORRECT WHAT IS CLEARLY WRONG
AND WITH THAT I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ADICIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER MONEY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I TO
URGENT NINE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
BELL.
HI WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
DOT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO -- BURKE BY WHAT COUNTY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
NO.
CENTER MONEY MOVES TO CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHTY TO
NINETY ONE AND NINETY TWO SHE'S
PREPARED THEIR PRISON ON FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SENATE JACKSON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THIS IS AB SIX SIX NINE IT'S A
BILL THAT AUTHORIZES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. TO USE A TYPE
OF SETTLEMENT TOOL CALLED AN
ASSURANCE OF VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE OR AVC FOR SHORT.
IT'S LIKE SETTLEMENT LIGHT IS
PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TO EXPLAIN
IT AND IN MULTI STATE CASES
INVOLVING CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
STATES OUR SISTER STATES
COMMONLY USED THESE ABC'S.
THE SUBTLE WITH DEFENDANTS OFTEN
IN CONSUMER PROTECTION OR
ENVIRONMENTAL ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THESE ARE GENERALLY
ENFORCEABLE BY THE COURT UNDER
THOSE OTHER ABC STATUTE.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THERE
IS NO EXPRESS LEGAL AUTHORITY
FOR THESE A. B. C.'S ARE THAT
ARE ENFORCEABLE BY THE COURT IF
THE DEFENDANT DOESN'T COMPLY
WITH THE TERMS OF THE SETTLEMENT
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THOSE SETTLEMENTS.
WITH LIMITED EXCEPTIONS.
THIS MEASURE WILL HELP
STREAMLINE SETTLEMENTS IN MULTI
STATE CASES AND PREVENT
UNNECESSARY ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION COSTS THUS ASSURING
MORE EFFICIENT USE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
RESOURCES THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE SENATORS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
XENON MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
I ARCH LETTER AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
YOUR TOTAL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON.
I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
BY OBERG I HAVE A COUNTY BY
WINNER.
WILK.
HI HI.
CENTER JACKSON MOVES TO CALL.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY TWO OF SENATOR GROWTH.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SOME OF THOSE SEVEN A SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AB
SEVEN OH SIX WILL SUPPORTER
CUMAE COLLEGE FACULTY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO KEEP THEIR
EARNED AN YOU SICK TIME BY
TRANSFERRING IT BETWEEN THE JOBS
ANOTHER DISTRICTS BEYOND THEIR
CURRENT THREE YEAR LIMITATION.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A
DIFFICULTY COLLEGE FACULTY
MEMBER WISHES TO KEEP THEIR AND
YOU SICK LEAVE.
THE MESS TO TRANSFER IT FROM
THEIR CURRENT EMPLOYER CURRENT
DISTRICT TO ANOTHER THEY HAVE TO
DO IT WITHIN THREE YEARS THE
TERMINATION.
OF THAT PREVIOUS EMPLOYMENT OR-THEY LOSE IT.
THIS ARBITRARY RESTRICTION OF
THREE YEARS CREATES AN
UNNECESSARY BARRIER IN KEEPING
PASSION AND QUALITY FACULTY
TEACHERS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
REALISTICALLY THEY CAN'T
DETERMINE WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO
GET SICK AND IF THEY DON'T GET
SICK FOR THE FOURTH YEAR LET'S
I'M TAKING IN THE FOURTH OR
FIFTH OR SIX YEAR.
SO -- PART TIME TEACHERS WHO
HAVE VERNE SICK LEAVE DESERVE TO
BE ABLE TO USE IT REGARDLESS OF
HOW LONG THAT THEY'VE BEEN
TEACHING.
AB SEVEN OH SIX REMOVE THE
RESTRICTIONS FOR FACULTY AND AN
EXCESS AT LIVE IN TO ACCESS
BENEFITS.
THAT THEY'VE EARNED IN THIS BILL
IS SPONSORED BY THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I HARSH LETTER.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DELHI [inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE ALTHOUGH.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ.
HI.
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
I WITH SO [inaudible] FOR TITLE.
I JACKSON.
HI I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
MORRELL.
BY NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN.
I STONE BY AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY [inaudible]
I WINNER.
WILK HI HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL.
FILE ITEM.
NINETY ONE SENATOR PAN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS UP.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND ACT
REALLY IN THE BUSINESS.
SENATOR PAN THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS AT TEN THIRTY TWO MAKES
REASONABLE EXPANSION TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS REGARDING TICKET
SALES.
OFTEN TICKETS TO POPULAR SHOWS
ARE SNAPPED UP BY ONLINE BOX
WHICH THEN RAPIDLY REALISTS
THOSE TICKETS ON RESELL
PLATFORMS AT INFLATED PRICES.
RECOGNIZING THIS AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE LEGISLATURE MADE IT
A CRIME TO USE BOTS TO BUY AND
RESELL TICKETS IN BULK.
AB TEN THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES A
LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW.
UNDER AB TEN THIRTY TWO FIRST
PARTY SERVICES THAT SERVE THE
SAME PURPOSE IS BUYING AND
SELLING TICKETS SIMPLE WILL ALSO
BE ILLEGAL.
THE BILL ALSO MAKES CLEAR WHO
YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT WITH
THESE LAWS THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIAN.
WISHING TO ATTEND THE SHOWS THIS
BILL IS ENJOYED A UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT HAS NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
ARE STRICTLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCH LETTER BY ATKINS.
I BATES.
I BILL.
I BRIDGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT OFF.
I CHIANG.
DELI.
I DOT [inaudible]
DURAZO.
I GALGIANI HI [inaudible]
DODD I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible]
YOUR TOTAL.
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE HAMBURG IA OUT SEE I WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER PAN MOVES TO A CALL.
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO SENATOR
GONZALEZ YOU PREPARE TO TAKE
THIS ITEM UP.
I AM MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
AND NATURALLY INTO ELECTIONS.
CENTER GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATE COLLEAGUES
ARE AB TEN FORTY FOUR AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND
SPONSORED BY OUR SECRETARY OF
STATE ALEX PADILLA.
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO REQUIRE
RECIPIENTS OF VOTER REGISTRATION
INFORMATION. TO COMPLETE A FREE
ONLINE SUB CYBERSECURITY COURSE
WHILE THE STATE STORES AND
RESTRICT ACCESS. TO BORDER
INFORMATION AND REGISTRATION --
INFORMATION CERTAIN INFORMATION
IS MADE AVAILABLE TO POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS
AND JOURNALISTS AMONG MANY
OTHERS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
TO SEPARATE MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HELD VOTER REGISTRATION
INFORMATION EXPERIENCE CYBER
ATTACKS.
BY ENSURING THAT RECIPIENTS OF
VOTER REGISTRATION DATA HAVE
COMPLETED BASIC CYBERSECURITY
LESSONS THIS BILL WILL HELP
SAFEGUARD THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF MILLIONS OFCALIFORNIANS.
AND ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN IN OUR SECRETARY OF STATE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NON MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES BY BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO -- TALA.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR GONZALEZ MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT FILE ITEM [inaudible]
NINETY EIGHT SENATOR HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH FOUR
BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT AND THEY'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT SENATOR HILL
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR WHICH GIVES
EMPLOYERS ANOTHER MECHANISM TO
REPORT SERIOUS INJURIES TO CAL
OSHA.
SPECIFICALLY THIS MEASURE WILL
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO REPORT THESE
SERIOUS INCIDENTS THROUGH AN
ONLINE MECHANISM.
INSTEAD OF EMAIL WHILE RETAINING
THE OPTION TO REPORT BY
TELEPHONE.
THIS PURPOSE THIS UPDATE IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE EMPLOYERS WHO
REPORT AN INJURY OR FATALITY BY
EMAIL CAN NEGLECT TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
WORKPLACE INCIDENT.
WHEN CAL OSHA RECEIVED AN
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION?
ITS ABILITY TO PROMPTLY INITIATE
AN INVESTIGATION OR TAKEN ANY
OTHER ACTION IS SIGNIFICANTLY
CURTAILED IMPACT THEIR ABILITY
TO EFFECTIVELY INSURE WORKPLACE
SAFETY THIS MEASURE HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIFLE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DOT.
ARE THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ.
I GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO [inaudible] FOR
TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL.
BY MORNING I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
I AMBERG.
OUR CASSIE.
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED SENATOR FURTADO WERE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE SIDE
OF MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY NEW COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR HER DAUGHTER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
MEMBERS TODAY I'M TALKING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS ON AB.
TWO THREE NINE AB TWO THREE NINE
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
CURRENT LAW TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS TO UTILIZE THE MULTI
CRITERIA SCREENING TOOL FOR
ADMISSIONS.
THE MULTI CRITERIA SCREENING
TOOL ALLOWS NURSING PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACT ON ADMISSIONS
BY ASSESSING A CANDIDATE'S
QUALIFICATIONS.
AND DECREASING ATTRITION RATES
FOR ENSURING THAT ENTRANCE INTO
THE PROGRAM ARE ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO UNDERTAKE THE COURSE
REQUIREMENTS.
CERTAINLY FORTY TWO NURSING
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
USE THE M. C. S. T. WITH MORE
WAITING UNTIL IT IS EXTENDED
AGAIN.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR D'AMATO DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
DORADO.
DOT DOT I DORADO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER.
I GONZALEZ HI.
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA.
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
I MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL.
BY NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
BY AMBERG.
OUR COUNTY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR FURTADO MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN SENATOR JONES ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
ONE OH SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAIN AND ACT IN
A PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTEEN
WHICH EXTENDS THE SUNSET FOR
LEGAL DOCUMENT ASSISTANCE. TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR LEGAL DOCUMENT
ASSISTANCE ARE AN IMPORTANT AND
AFFORDABLE PART OF THE LEGAL
PROCESS AND THIS BILL ALLOWS
THEIR VALUE POSITION TO CONTINUE.
AB TWELVE THIRTEEN HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE SIDE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL.
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ.
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG.
IA CASKEY I WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
HI BY SENATOR JONES MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN SENATOR PORTANTINO ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE THIS ITEM
UP.
ALL RIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ.
AND ACT RELATED STATE CLAIMS
MAKING PROGRESS THERE FOR AND
CLAIM THEIR STRESS TAKE VICTIMS.
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU AYE
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTY IS AN URGENCY
MEASURE TO APPROPRIATE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD FOR
THE PAYMENT OF FIVE STATE CLAIMS
RELATED TO THE AROUND HIS
CONVICTIONS.
ARE MARCO CONTRASTS EMMANUEL
PASSED THE LOPEZ DASH ONE READ
AND HORACE ROBERTS AND TIMOTHY
EIGHT CAN ATKINS.
IN EACH OF THESE CASES THE COURT
SET ASIDE THE CONVICTIONS AND
MADE A FINDING OF FACTUAL
INNOCENCE EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
THE BOARD TO RECOMMEND AN
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THESE
CLAIMS.
WITHOUT A HEARING THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS APPROVED PAYMENT
OF THESE CLAIMS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM IS HERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM.
ONE ELEVEN SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY COMING AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY.
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO.
JACKSON HI I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
BY STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL WE'RE GOING
TO GO NOW.
OR LAST ITEM ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING IS FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTEEN SENATOR BATES.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SOME OCCUR RESOLUTION NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
REAL TO TO SECURE YOUR LOW DAY.
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
CHOI I RISE TO PRESENT ACR.
NINETY FIVE THE CLEARING JUNE
SIXTH THAT SECURE YOUR LOW DAY
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS THE NATION'S MOST POPULOUS
STATE WITH MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ON
THE ROADS EVERY DAY CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THE ROADS AND ADDRESS NAY
INTERESTS ROAD DEBRIS.
A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE TRIPLE
A FOUNDATION FOR TRAFFIC SAFETY
SHOWS THAT NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
DEATHS AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCIDENTS ARE THE
RESULT OF UNSECURED LOADS EACH
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
ETHAN HAWKE'S A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD SENIOR FROM WHITTIER
CHRISTIAN HIGH SCHOOL WAS THE
VICTIM OF A TRAGIC ACCIDENT IN
ORANGE.
EVEN WAS SITTING IN THE
PASSENGER SEAT WHILE HIS MOTHER
DROVE HIM TO PICK UP A GIRL ON
HIS FIRST DATE SADLY EVEN WAS
FATALLY INJURED WHEN A HEAVY
PIECE OF METAL FELL OFF.
ANOTHER VEHICLE AND ON TO
THERE'S THIS TRAGIC ACCIDENT MAY
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED IF
INDIVIDUALS PROPER PROPERLY
SECURED THEIR CARGO LOADS.
ACR NINETY FIVE SEEKS TO BRING
AWARENESS TO CALIFORNIANS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SECURING ONE
SLOWED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
I'M SORRY SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
NINETY FIVE AS A MOTORCYCLE
RIDER ON CALIFORNIA'S BUSY
FREEWAYS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS.
ASPECTS OF MARCECA WRITING IS --
LOADS -- AND SECURED AND SO I DO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND
WANTED TO RAISE THAT AWARENESS
THAT. FOR THE SAFETY OF JUST --
AUTOMOBILE MOTORISTS BUT ALSO
MOTORCYCLE MOTORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SINGING HEARING NON CENTER BATES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARTS LETTER [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PURCHASED [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GONZALEZ.
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON HI I JONES.
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
I'M RAIL [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS HE I WINNER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER BATES MOVES A CALL.
MOVING NOW BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HE VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
PASS THE TO FOLLOW NUMBER ONE
FIVE SEVEN A. B. NINE IN THE TO
BE REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SO NOTED AND ADDITIONALLY FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THREE FOUR A. B.
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE ALSO REMOVED
FOR THE CONSENT COUNTER THERE
WILL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU.
AGAIN UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL DIVIDE THE
FOLLOWING.
THREE RESOLUTIONS FROM THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR AND
PLACE THEM ON THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THEY ARE ACR FOR ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FOUR A SHE OUR THIRTY
EIGHT ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE AND A C. R.
FORTY SEVEN ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN ARE WE ARE
GOING TO GO NOW TO A JOURNEY IN
MEMORIES AT WHICH POINT IN TIME
WE WILL CALL -- AFTER WHICH WE
WILL CALL ALL OUR MEMBERS BACK
SO THAT WE CAN.
REMOVE THE CALLS WITH THE CALLS
ON ALL THE ITEMS VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- AND THEN
ADJOURN SO WITH THAT ARE THERE
ANY ADJOURNING MEMORIES
[inaudible]
SENATOR MORALE -- THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
HANNAH HAD MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I RISE TODAY TO
GERMAN IN THE MEMORY OF A MAN
WHO WAS A FIXTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR YEARS.
DR LLOYD WALKER -- DOCTOR WALKER
WAS BORN IN OHIO IN NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR BUT MOVED.
TO MY END OF THE STATE -- IN
SALMON DINO WHERE HE ATTENDED
SCHOOL AND DID VERY WELL IN
ACADEMICS AND SPORTS IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX DOCTOR WALKER JOINED
THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE
RESERVES.
IN SERVE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
TELL HE WAS HONORABLY DISCHARGED
AFTER LEAVING SERVICE HE
ATTENDED SAN MARINO VALLEY
COLLEGE AND ALSO WORK FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
HE ALSO MOVED NORTH -- IN
ATTENDED CSU RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE HE EARNED HIS
DOCTOR -- DOCTOR OF DENTAL
SURGERY DEGREE -- AND THEN --
WENT ON TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL OF DENTISTRY.
FROM SEVENTY NINE TO A TWO
THOUSAND ONE HE OPERATED A
PRIVATE PRACTICE IN LA.
AND THEN HE WAS HIRED ON AS THE
STAFF DENNIS WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT -- IN RETIREMENT
EVENTUALLY RETIRED IN A DOCTOR
WALKER REMAIN ACTIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SERVING AS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
CHAPTER.
OF THE HUNDRED BLACK MEN OF
AMERICA HE LOVES -- HIS LOVE
ONCE DESCRIBED HIMSELF SPOKEN
AND VERY CARING WHO OFTEN SHARED
ON POINT ADVICE AND WISDOM.
DOCTOR WALKER SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN
THIS THREE BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS.
AND OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS A HOST
OF FAMILY MEMBERS MEMBERS I ASK
YOU IF YOU WOULD TO PLEASE JOIN
US IN HONORING THE MEMORY OF DR
LLOYD WALKER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR OF MORALITY IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE BRING THE
DOCTOR'S NAME FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN PROPERLY.
MEMORIALIZE HIM IN OUR
CONDOLENCES OF COURSE TO HIS
FAMILY.
SENATOR HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR ROBERT LEVINE.
MR LEVINE WAS A BELOVED SOCIAL
PSYCHOLOGIST WHO DEVOTED MOST OF
HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE CAN RICH
IN THE MINDS OF STUDENTS.
HE PLAYED AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS A
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHOLOGY.
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRESNO WHERE HE TALKED FOR FORTY
SIX YEARS.
HIS PASSION HIS PASSION FOR
EXPLORING CULTURE HAPPINESS AND
SOCIAL AND SICK CALL
PSYCHOLOGICAL QUALITY OF LIFE.
INFLUENCE THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
AND MANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES.
INCLUDING MYSELF.
HE TRAVELED THE WORLD AND FOCUS
MUCH OF HIS WORK ON STARTING
PERCEPTIONS OF TIME AND PIECES
OF LIFE.
HE SERVED AS A VISITING
PROFESSOR AND UNIVERSITIES IN
BRAZIL JAPAN SWEDEN AND THE UK.
ALTHOUGH THE CENTRAL VALLEY LOST
AN AMAZING LEADER HIS LEGACY IS
FOR EVER THREADED INTO OUR
STORIES.
THE DOCTOR LEVIN'S BOLD WORK
HYSTERECTOMY THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE.
CHALLENGING ALL OF US TO REFLECT
ON HOW WE CAN BREAK DOWN OUR OWN
INTERNAL BARRIERS.
IN A SENSE HE WAS A TRAILBLAZER
FOR CULTIVATING A COMMUNITY THAT
CONTINUES TO CELEBRATE DIVERSITY.
DOCTOR LEVINE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE JUDY AND THE SONS AND THE
IN STOCK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE AGAIN BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM AND HIS
SERVICE.
AND ARE SENATE CONDOLENCES
POLICE TO HIS FAMILY
[inaudible]
SENATOR GROVE [inaudible]
FORESHORES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
RAISE TWO INJURED IN MEMORY OF
BAKERSFIELD RESIDENT VICTORIA
HOSEY WHO PASSED AWAY -- JUST
RECENTLY SHE'S JUST CELEBRATED
HER ONE HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY IN
MAY.
BORN IT MAY FOURTEENTH NINETEEN
NINETEEN AND HURRICANE ALABAMA
SHE WAS THE SECOND ELDEST OF TEN
CHILDREN.
SHE ATTENDED A LOCAL SCHOOL IN
BAY MINETTE -- WHERE SHE MET HER
FUTURE HUSBAND CHARLIE WOODROW
HOSEY AND THEY WERE WAY AHEAD ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FOURTH?
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN VICTORIA
HER HUSBAND AND TEN CHILDREN
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA IN THE QUIET
TOWN OF GREENFIELD WHERE THEY
BOTH SHE AND HER HUSBAND WORKED
AS RANCH HANDS ON OF FRANK
DELFINO AS RANCH.
VICTORIA'S ELEVENTH CHILD WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AFTER THEY MOVED AND SETTLED IN
BAKERSFIELD.
VICTORIA WORKED HARD TO PROVIDE
FOR HER FAMILY NOT ONLY
FINANCIALLY BUT SPIRITUALLY
SHIPS ACTED CRISIS IN EARLY IN
AN EARLY AGE IN ALABAMA AND SHE
STAYED INVOLVED IN OUR LOCAL
CHURCH.
AFTER SHE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
LATER BECOMING THE CHURCH MOTHER
IN A CHOIR MEMBER AT THE FIRST
COMMUNITY BAPTIST CHURCH IN
BAKERSFIELD.
SHE SERVED OUR COMMUNITY TIRES
TIRELESSLY THROUGH HER VOLUNTEER
WORK AND DISTRIBUTING FOOD TO
FAMILIES IN NEED ALL THE WHILE
CARING FOR HER OWN KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS.
SHE WOULD PREPARE HOT HOME
COOKED MEALS IN FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
FAMILIES AND IN FROM HER OWN
KITCHEN AND OWNING DINNER TABLE.
IT IS COMMON PLACE AT HER HOME
TO AWAIT TO NIECES NEPHEWS A
NEIGHBORHOOD KIDS SLEEPING ON
COUCHES FLOORS OR WHEREVER FLOOR
SPACE PERMITTED.
COVERED WITH HAND MADE QUILTS
THAT SHE HAD MADE HERSELF HER
DEVOTION TO LET LEVY AND CARING
FOR OTHERS DID NOT GO UNNOTICED
IN FACT MAYOR KAREN GO OF THE
CITY OF BAKERSFIELD.
PROCLAIM TO MAY EIGHTEENTH AS
VICTORIA HOSEY DAY.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER SISTER
LILA FIVE SENS FOUR DAUGHTERS
FIFTY EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND
SEVENTY ONE GREAT GRAND CHILDREN.
HEY AND THIRTY ONE GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THIS WOMAN HAS
TRULY LEFT A LEGACY OF FAITH AND
FAMILY AND GIVING SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY I AM HONORED TO
REPRESENT OF HIS HONOR TO
REPRESENT HER BEFORE SHE PASSED
AWAY.
IN THE STATE SENATE AND IT SAM
MY HONOR TO ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE AND
WE'LL DO OUR BEST TO MEMORIALIZE
HER TO ALL HER.
FAMILY -- CERTAINLY WOMAN WHO --
SHARED WITH US THE BOUNTY OF
HAVING SUCH A LARGE FAMILY.
NEXT ARE CENTER GROVE OF FOR A
DAVID MARCUS.
ON A JOURNEY MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SEEMS LIKE
BAKERSFIELD IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
LOST -- SIGNIFICANT LEADERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY INCLUDING VICTORIA
HOSEY IN THE TWO THAT I DID LAST
WEEK.
AB DAVID MARCUS -- PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY JUST A REMARKABLE MAN.
HE IS -- A FRIEND TO ALL HE WAS
AN INSPIRATION TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT WAS A CANCER FIGHTER.
DAVID WASN'T BORN IN BAKERSFIELD
BUT HE MADE HIS WAY ON HIS HOME
HERE IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHEN HE WAS
BORN IN NEW JERSEY AND HIS
FAMILY LEFT NEW JERSEY AND
SETTLED IN SALINAS CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE SERVICE THAT THEY
PROVIDED TO THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED COMMUNITY.
AND ON THEIR WAY THE AFTER THAT
THEY MADE THEIR WAY TO
BAKERSFIELD IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE BECAUSE OF THE BAKERSFIELD
ARC.
DAVID HAD WAS FIRST DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER IN TWENTY TEN AND
SEE BEGAN AROUND OF CHEMOTHERAPY.
DEFIED DESPITE HIS BATTLE WITH
CANCER -- IT DIDN'T END.
AFTER THAT HE HE SURVIVED HIS
FIRST SECOND THIRD FOURTH FIFTH
AND SIXTH VICTORY I'M AS A
CANCER SURVIVOR FOR VIBE
SURVIVOR.
HE BARELY OVERCOME AND CANCER
SIX INCREDIBLE TIMES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS LAST BATTLE
THE SEVENTH ONE TOOK HIS LIFE
[inaudible]
AND IN OUR COMMUNITY AND I KNOW
A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE WE PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
PEOPLE WHEN HE WAS THE BEST
BAGGER.
THAT YOU COULD GET AN AT
ALBERTSONS AND HE ALWAYS MADE
SURE YOUR GROCERIES WERE PACKED
VERY VERY WELL.
WITH OTHER COMMUNITY LEADERS
DAVID REALIZE THE POWER OF
POSITIVITY AND HOW MUCH A SIMPLE
GESTURE COULD MAKE SO THEY
STARTED A PROGRAM IN IT IN A
NONPROFIT CALLED THUMBS UP IN
CANCER DOWN.
DAVID STARTED THE SUMS UP CANCER
DOWN NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WHICH IS DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH CANCER.
THROUGH ENCOURAGEMENT AND CARE
PACKAGES HE WAS ALSO KNOWN AS A
SUPERIOR AND SUPER HERO FANTA
CENTENNIAL HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HIS
BEAUTIFULNIECES WENT TO SCHOOL.
WITH A BIG THUMBS UP IN A SMILE
AND A POSITIVE ATTITUDE DAVID
MARCUS INSPIRED BAKER STILL
COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS ALL THE
WHILE BATTLING CANCER.
DAVID WAS NAMED BAKERSFIELD
GREATEST COMMUNITY SUPPORTER
WHICH IS SEEN THROUGHOUT HIS
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT OF
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE LEAVE OF
LEAGUE OF DREAMS HONOR FLIGHT.
RELAY FOR LIFE CAMP OUT AGAINST
CANCER AND MANY MORE.
DAVID FOUGHT AND FOUGHT WITH OUR
COMMUNITY ANDWE FOUGHT WITH HIM
IN JUST A FEW DAYS AGO HE LOST
HIS LIKE TO CANCER WITH HIS
FAMILY BY HIS BEDSIDE.
THIS YOUNG MAN WAS TRULY AN
AMAZING INDIVIDUAL IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND THERE WASN'T
ANYTHING THAT HE DIDN'T
ENCOUNTER AND THAT HE DIDN'T
HAVE A POSITIVE ATTITUDE FOR SO
I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU
ENTERED IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BEGIN LIFTING CALLS ON BILLS.
WE WILL START WITH SR.
FIFTY ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY
SENATOR DODD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
PAN NOTIFY [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I FELL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HUESO.
HI LEYVA.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
BY.
I WAS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO AB.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE OUR MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I CHIANG MITCHELL.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM.
FORTY TWO OF US DREAD.
THUNDERSTONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ATKINS.
I BILL.
I CHIANG.
DAWALY SYSTEM -- GLAZER.
HI WITH SO.
I LEYVA AYE AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
I TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR
A. B. FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WEBER
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS.
HI BILL.
I CHIANG WITH SO.
I LEYVA.
I PORTANTINO.
I SKINNER.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
I THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY NINE A. B.
FIVE NINETY ONE GARCIA PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I SKINNER.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
I PAGE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FIFTY AB SIX NINETY
THREE BERMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BELL.
I BURGESS NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
WITH SO.
I LEYVA.
BY SKINNER.
I WIENER [inaudible]
BY.
I JUST TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BURGESS.
BRETT NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I LEYVA.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO.
ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY WIENER [inaudible]
I BRADFORD I PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RUBIO.
EYES TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY
AB SIX SIXTY NINE HOLDEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
I WITH SO.
BY LEYVA.
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
I THREE NINE OH ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB
SEVEN OH SIX LOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HUESO.
BY LEYVA.
I MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG MORLOCK. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB THIRTEEN
AT TEN ZERO TEN THIRTY TWO QUIRK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WERE JUST [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I LEYVA.
HI WIENER.
AYE.
AYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO AB TEN FORTY FOUR
IRWIN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY.
GORGEOUS.
BY CARRIER ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY HUESO.
I LEYVA.
HI WIENER [inaudible]
I I THIRTY NINE OH ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT AB EIGHTEEN OH FOUR KALRA
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
BY CHIANG GALGIANI [inaudible]
OUR GROWTH.
I WITH SO.
HI LEYVA.
HI WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
I WAS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
GORGEOUS.
BY CARRIER -- I CHIANG.
LEYVA.
I STERN.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
BY.
I THIRTY NINE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE OF
SEVEN AB TWELVE THIRTEEN CHEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI GORGEOUS.
HI KELLY HERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROW.
HI LEYVA.
HI WIENER [inaudible]
I COPYRIGHT.
I WAS THIRTY NINE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY BY
GONZALEZ PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THE ALLEN.
HI FOR JUST.
HI CARRIER -- I CHIANG FURTADO.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
I EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN ACR.
NINETY FIVE ARE CHOI CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE WIENER [inaudible]
BY.
I THIRTY NINE TWO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THOSE ITEMS.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FOR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT IN THE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OUR I ARCILLA BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL I PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ.
HI GROVE.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
HI WITH SO.
BY OUR TOTAL [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
AYE MITCHELL.
HI [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
BY KELSEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI FI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HANG TIGHT MEMBERS
PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHIANG.
SKINNER NUMBER.
HI.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED
[inaudible]
MEMBERS THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
READ THE ITEMS.
A SOME OF THE SOME.
431-428-57240 529-936-1380
1-453-473-4074 NINETY FOUR BY
666-056-08619 634-640-4670.
276-672-7290 988-981-00010
891-160-1180 312-401-39214
211-532-59760. SIXTY TWO
EIGHTEEN TO EIGHTEEN OH THREE
SILICON CARRILLO XIN. FORTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX BUT THE MAJORA'S
LUCIEN EIGHT SOME OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY NINE EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY SENATE BILL FOUR
THIRTY TWO ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY ONE AND ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX THIRTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY EYES THREE NINE NO
ZERO THIS A SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED
[inaudible]
WHAT?
CENTER WILL FOR PURPOSE THE RICE.
I BEEN STANDING TO REMOVE --
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR A. B.
TWELVE FORTY FROM I APOLOGIZE
WOMAN WEBER.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL PURSUE THE
DEATH WILL KNOW IT WILL REMOVE
IT SORRY ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOUR MINUTES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED ITEM THIRTY EIGHT BILL
NUMBER AB.
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN ITEM NINETY
THREE A. B. A LOT.
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR MEMBERS DO WE
HAVE ANY ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
HERTZBERG -- UPON ADJOURNMENT
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS I THE MEDI
LOUNGE IMMEDIATELY UPON THE
GERMAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
VERY BUSY TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY
AHEAD OF US.
HI -- I HOPE YOU ALL ARE ABLE TO
GO HOME FOR JULY FOURTH AND
SPEND THE TIME WITH YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND HAVING SAID THAT WE WILL BE
BACK ON FRIDAY JULY FIFTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN AT NINE THIRTY
AM THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS THE
SENATE IS IN RECESS WE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE THIRTY
AM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED WELL